大家好,我是QQ球模。
在这一节课的话,跟大家分享了这个5分钟短线交易系统的一个核心思想。
呃,大家对于我这个交易系统的一个构成呢,可能也有一定的一个了解了。
那么接下来的话,就是跟大家分享如何去做这个开箱交易。
呃,那么识别这个有效的开箱信号,对于我们做交易的第一步来讲是特别的重要。
呃,很多人会认为就是交易系统的一个建立很简单,关键难度是在于这个人性上的一个管理。
呃,那其实是没错。
但是关键是你如果第一步都没做好,那么你做后面的人性管理更加无从弹起。
所以说,呃,能否在开箱方面呃,成功,那么它会影响到你的一个交易的一个心态。
所以说,呃,我们这个交易好坏呢,其实呃,第一步关键就看我们能不能开好仓。
那么如何开好这个交易,如何开仓呢?
呃,这里我会在这个做多,还有做好两方面,还有正当这三方面,来给大家做一个简单的交流。
呃,那么其实对于开仓,呃,我们知道,
我们现在每个参与交易的人很多,所以交易系统都特别的不一样。
那么我们这个交易系统是基于这个技术分析,就像有一些粉丝说的,呃,我们这个系统呢,就是一个军线的一个系统。
呃,其实也没错,核心就是军线。呃,那么我们这里的话,5分钟的250日军线,呃,就是这么个情况。
呃,关于这个做多开仓的话,呃,在我们这个信号里面其实也有很多。
当时呢,我这里两个图呢,呃,两个信号呢,啊,主要是我总结发现的,啊,在多数的行情里面呢,啊,出现的概率频率比较高的两种。
那么其实你做到,你只要把这两个信号,啊,都能够做到了,那么其实你的收益也会很可怕。
而且最重要的,因为这两个信号你熟悉之后,那么你的胜率也会高很多。
当然我说我选所选的这两个信号呢,只是说我们行情里面遇到的比较典型的一些信号,啊,但不代表没有其他的信号。
那么这个其他信号能不能捕捉到,那这个跟你这个交易的一个时间经验,还有就是你的经验,啊,你的盘感。
等方面都有关系,那么这里的话,就是重点的就跟大家做这两个信号的一个讲解。
呃,那么第一个信号呢,就是说我在下跌的一个行情过程中啊,我什么时候出现了一个做多的一个信号。
因为其实我们这个五分钟系统呢,其实在做这个拐点的行情特别的好用,啊,那么这两个图形的基本上也能够看出它就是一个拐点的行情。
只不过这个拐点呢,有些人呢,就会被这个假信号迷惑了,有些人呃,被迷惑了,呃,迷惑了,
所以呢,就是会出现一个交易失败的一个情况,那么这里的话,我们就来,所以说,呃,如何能够比较好的做好,呃,这个开仓,呃,的一个成功率。
呃,那么第一个呢,就是我的这个形态,当我这个K线,像这个2550日线突破之后啊,那么第二经过这个回彩,在2550日线得到成功的支撑之后,
继续往上走,突破这个高点往上走的这个情况,那之后说呢,我们去做单,我们去做单,那么这种,这就有第一种信号。
第二种呢,就是说,我呃,虽然啊,突破了,突破了,但是呢,经过它第二次回彩的时候,它2550日线没支撑到,那么可以说它这个可能是一个假突破,那之后呢,
我们可能就不去参与,那么再次回到这个,再次向上突破这个2550日线,那么可能我们就会去参与,啊,我们会去参与。
呃,呃,那么如果,呃,参与,那么如果,呃,如果是说它,哎,像又出现这个回调,当一当它这个破了这个2550日线的时候呢,那可能就要去做试试。
呃,有时候呢,如果我们介绍时机好刚好发现的时候,它还走到这个第三步这个回彩确认的时候呢,那我们再去最终的参与,那么这个行情呢,我们基本上就能够很好,很好地做到。
呃,我们就能够做到一个比较大的一个行情,而且像这种不停的一个震荡,震荡,震荡,假突破,假突破,这种情况呢,那么可能后面就会有一波比较大的一个行情。
那这个时候呢,你去抓,可能都会有一些意料之外的一些收获。呃,那么这里的话,这两种形态呢,呃,其实第一种呢,是一个比较理想的一个形态。
那么它出现,虽然是理想,但是它在我们行情的一个走势里面呢,其实这种形态也是经常会有出现的。
呃,大家可以去看一看,发现,发现一下。呃,那么第二种形态呢,这种形态呢,是呃,呃,就是什么呢,就是最喜人的一种行情吧。
那么如果是说你的一个经验不到位,你的旁岗不好,那么可能就会被洗,被洗,被洗出来,那么被洗出来之后呢,你可能就会错过了这个行情。
哎,一旦错过之后呢,即使后面还有很大的行情,你可能也不会去参与了,因为你这个时候呢,觉得太高了,等不会去参与了。
当然如果你掌握这种信号的时候呢,你,你会发现,啊,它高了没关系,只要它回彩50和回彩这个250日线,都是你一个借助的一个机会,都是你一个借助的机会。
呃,那么这两种信号呢,如果你能够掌握这两种信号的,那基本上多数很多这个行情呢,呃,也能够你吃上一步比较好的一个盈利,比较好的盈利。
当然你可能也会发现还有一个频率比较高的一个行情是什么呢,就是说我直接突破这个,呃,250日线之后呢,就一直往上走,一直往上走,走出一个很大的一个行情。
那这个时候呢,如果按照我们这种回彩确认,呃,再去做多的这种方式啊,那么可能我会错过这一个直接突破之后上载的这种行情。
其实我觉得这个没关系,因为什么呢,因为我们,啊,我们做交易的,我们第一个,我们是要保证我们的胜率,因为如果我直接少的话,呃,我如果是说出现不停的止损,那么我可能我本情都会被我自身弯。
所以我们追求的一个是胜率,第二呢,我们有会比较大的一个盈亏比。啊,那么像这种偶尔突破之后,一突破就马上走出一个大行情,这种也是一定概率上的,它也不仅是百分之百的。
那我就没必要是说一定要去抓这个行情,啊,那个抓得到,那当然是运气好,啊,做不到,那,那你说那个,呃,你这个,这个形态就不好了。
所以呢,我们做我们熟悉的,像,正常来讲,为什么我不认,我,我,我不是很建议,就是说一突破之后呢,就去做追,追这个行情。
因为在一个比较大的一个下跌行情,末端的一个下跌行情里面的,那你要发生反转,它不可能马上就是多头就脚下投降,啊,然后空头马上就占据主动的位置了。
通常都会有一个斗争的一个过场,说呢,会有这种反复,啊,这个才是正常的现象,啊,如果是说一,一条线直接突破,然后走出一个很大的行情呢,这种行情呢,这个,这个,呃,真的不适合说,啊,除了运气,我觉得实力这个东西也很难讲,很难讲。
所以我们做的话,我们做我们认为合理的一个行情去做就可以了。当然还有一些像,呃,这里,呃,这第二个信号这里的,我们知道虽然它是震荡啊,但是震荡,如果你关系,观察,仔细一点点,然后会发现,它每一次虽然是破了这个,而保持是日线之后呢,继续往下跌。
那么往下跌它回产的一个低点呢,它又不会高于前面的低点,而不会低于它前面的低点,那为什么它,它这个低点呢,其实它出现,它也有一定的依据的,你可以去看一下这个三分钟的二百五十日军线,或者是五分钟的一百二十日军线,啊,你会发现可能到这两个线呢,它就基本上就在这个自身自己的点位,然后就出现了一个继续反弹,啊,继续反弹。
那么,反弹完之后,啊,就会回彩这个五十日军线,当你回彩五十日军线之后继续往上跌,那基本上这个多头的一个单,你就可以拖拖的拿住了。
那么这个回彩这个这个地点,那么,啊,可能,啊,我们经验比较充足的呢,可能会在这个回彩这个点,回彩这个点的时候,我们就去介入了,啊,介入之后呢,我们这个吃餐的这个,呃,产品就有优势,当然你在这个地方去介入的话是最好的。
啊,是最好的。啊,所以当这个东西没有任何的一个问题,没有任何的问题。
当这种好处呢,是什么呢?这种好处呢,就是比如我们在这个回彩的时候确认做到,我们这可能,就是这里有一条线,然后这里有一个K线,啊,可能一跟两个人的时候呢,它都是形式红色上涨的,那可能是我去介入。
那么即使错了,啊,就是它涨不上去,它往下掉的时候呢,也没问题,你可能就在这个地点,啊,做一个直损,或者是在50,啊,把50线做个直损,那么即使你在直损的成本是很低很低的。
这个也就是我们在后面说,呃,我们这个开枪系统呢,它寄给我们提供了一个很好的一个开枪的一个支撑,啊,开枪的一个信号的一个很有效的一个依据。
那么也给我们做个平产,也就是我们的直损,呃,指引提供了一个很好的依据,提好它很好的依据。
呃,那么其实关于这个做空的开枪呢,呃,其实跟我们做到开枪的逻辑是一样的,只不过这个方向发生了一个改变而已,发生了一个改变。
那么信号一跟我们做到的一个信号一,其实就是一百五十,一百八十多的一个,一个反转而已,对吧?
那么这个,这里的话,这个做空,这里我就不再去详细的说它,啊,具体的话,你们可以看这两个形态呢,去做,呃,去看,呃,去看那个。
把那行情调出来,你们去去看一下,啊,我这里就不调行情来跟大家详细说。
呃,可能郁门的一点呢,就是观望,呃,这个震荡的行情了,呃,我们知道,啊,因为做军线的话,它军线它反映的是一个比较之后的一个字。
所以有时候呢,我们看军线呢,我们是没办法,呃,判断它后面的行情,具体是怎么走的。
或者是说,行情它这个幅度能多大,啊,这个东西都不是我们判断的。
所以我们做的就是根据我们这个系统,啊,它出的信号去操作,去操作。
所以呢,其实在观望的行情里面呢,呃,我,我们刚才说的,啊,就是它下跌的过程中,像上涨转和变,或者是上涨的过程中,像下跌广变。
那么它,它这个转变的这个过程里面呢,可能就会出现这个学历,由正转负,或者由负转正。
那么这个时候呢,它会有一个趋先的一个问题啦。
那这个时候呢,就会出现一个震荡,啊,出现一个震荡。呃,所以呢,这个时候呢,我们出现这个震荡的时候呢,一般情况第一开始呢,我们都还是按照作动或者做空的这种信号去做。
那么做的时候呢,可能会出一到两次的情况,啊,那么这个时候呢,你发现,哎,它这个幅度,这个上涨,它下跌的幅度都不大,那么这个时候呢,可能你都会出现这种,啊,小盈利啊,或者小资损呢,或者是宝本,呃,出来,啊,宝本出来。
那么这个时候呢,你才能够确认,它可能就属于这个震荡行情。当它出现了这个学历啊,啊,这个学历,呃,向上倾斜,比较懂,或者向下倾斜,比较懂的,
那么这个时候呢,我们才能够去,呃,觉得它这个行情走出来了。那么这里的话,我可以补充跟大家判断一下,就是我怎么样去提前的预,预判,它可能这个学历变陡了,或者变,呃,变窄了。
那这个时候呢,你可以借助这个一百二十日军线,跟这个两百五十日军线的这个精差,跟死差,来提前的预判一下。那么这个其实是挺有一个,挺有效果的。
那么这些课的内容的话,就是呃,我这里的话就没有去把这个行情软件调出来,但是通过这两个图设呢,其实,如果你能把这些图设所,展示的这种信号,你能捕捉得到,那么其实啊,这些行情,其实都够做,都够做,呃,都是够做的。
呃,呃,当然这个更多的话,你们就是根据这些信号,你们去,呃,去,去打开这个行情软件,去,去发现一下,呃,看我这个说的这个有没有道理,你们可以去验证一下。
呃,包括你们在后面的实际的交易过程中也可以把带着这个问题,带着这个问题去看行情。
那么下一节的话,我们就是会在这一节讲完这个开仓之后呢,下一节我们就会讲这个评仓。
呃,这一节的话,我多少的带了一点点评仓的一个意识在里面。
呃,那下一节,我们就会具体对于这个评仓,呃,展开来讲,因为其实你开仓,呃,解决开仓的一步之后呢,你还得解决这个评仓的另外一步。
因为平常的话,有时候呢,就我们说的这个行情呢,可能持有的时间周期比较长,把这个波段行情比较大。
那这个时候呢,如果你,呃,你没有一个很系统,或者是很明确的这种平常信号的话,你可能会过早,呃,会过早的这个,把这个,把这个,把这个引力,呃,把这个引力丢掉。
所以的时候呢,我们,呃,很有必要谈一谈这个平常的一个策略。
下一节,如果你有兴趣,你们可以继续关注这个期货头条,呃,期货头的这个头条号期货。